people who just want to basically have
nothing good to say they just want to
bash and be critical of your channel
have you experienced that and how have
you dealt with that okay that is a great
question and that reminds me that when I
started a YouTube channel I honestly did
not know that commenters could be nice
because anything i had ever watched was
always some kind of a viral something
and when you start looking down the
comments they are absolutely horrible
and people just say anything that they
want to say i honestly did not know that
there was such a thing as believe nation
which is that's the community over under
under that's the community that watches
Evan Carmichael's videos the commenters
we call ourselves believe nation they
are amazing in so much support and I am
awed by the nice things that get said
there so thank you rishi and tim i
really appreciate it I appreciate the
shout out I appreciate your loyalty I
appreciate the goodness that you add to
the channel to the comments the energy
that you bring it's an honor and a
privilege to have you as a part of the
channel and thank you so much